foreign
baseball bats they'll be carrying pipes
knives what what have you any type of
weapon and they're really in a moment of
psychosis to where they are not making
sense they're screaming obscenities or
whatever and you have to walk past that
right people have to walk past that and
they have to deal with it and so it's
kind of jarring and can be really you
know traumatizing to some people
especially young children you know I
grew up around a lot of drug use and
people acting ironic uh you know um
and not acting right and it had an
impact on how um how I grew up
get home safe
[Music]
come on man
[Music]
after I made the video down here with
the children it created such a Ruckus
that they put up these fences like kind
of like again a grandstand to try to act
like they were going to do something and
I actually almost fell for it I was like
oh man we're having a policy change
we're gonna be doing a little bit better
out here and uh it just didn't turn out
like that it's just back to the business
as usual
um as soon as Brooke Jenkins got elected
it's like she should carry a response so
who cares uh and it's kind of sad that
these uh these neighbors have to be
sandwiching between eighth and Mission
and seventh admission both bus stops are
basically being hijacked by
um drug dealers and drug users and it's
turned into like one of the biggest
open-air drug markets here in San
Francisco uh and this is a main Corridor
for San Francisco this is not like some
back alley or like some uh um shoddy
part of town I pay
um 2500 uh dollars a month for a studio
apartment in this area area this is not
acceptable in my opinion that I should
have to live like this or or
deal with this when I come outside to
walk my dog or to see a family member my
family members don't even really like to
come down here and see me because of the
crime
you'll see some of the drug dealers
they're being wearing masks and ponchos
okay
this is the bus stop that I filmed the
children getting off it's kind of rough
right here to get off the bus I mean
it's a lot of homelessness a lot of drug
dealing going on it's kind of kind of
sad you know
you see this type of stuff
when you see the San Francisco police
Paddy Wagon parked right there but you
won't see anybody in the back of that
van and you won't even see the police
out here doing their job I mean we just
walked through one of the biggest
open-air drug markets here in San
Francisco and you'll see these people
just out there selling and smoking drugs
uh and it's raining outside right now
it's not uh really clear day it's pretty
ugly day to be out here so the activity
is actually low today and it's just
unbelievable that we can't get City
officials to do their job we cannot get
the San Francisco Police Department to
do their job to clean up our city so our
children and our family members are safe
walking down these streets it's very sad
[Music]